Did you ever hear the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the Wise?
I thought not.
Well, to make a long story short, Darth Plagueis
was a dark lord of the Sith, who was so powerful
that he could actually use the force to influence
midichlorians to prolong someone’s life
indefinitely, or even... create new life...
from nothing
Now, we’re of course not the ones to say
whether or not that’s actually possible,
and even if it was, we certainly wouldn’t
want to be the ones to teach you how to do it.
The dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some, including us here at
Journey to the Microcosmos, consider to be...
unnatural.
But, what we can teach you is more about midi-chlorians,
those powerful little beings that hold the
secrets of the force.
Midichlorians are sentient, microscopic organisms
that reside inside each and every living cell
of your body, and it’s believed they originated
at the Wellspring of Life, a mystical world
located in the center of the galaxy.
Over thousands of years, we have come to depend
on midichlorians just as they have come to
depend on us.
We have developed a symbiotic relationship.
We are two life forms, living together...
Well, actually we are way more than just two
life forms.
A person’s midichlorian count is determined
not by the number of midichlorians in their
body, but by the number of midichlorians per
cell in their body, and the average person’s
midichlorian count is around 2,500, which
means, they have about 2,500 midichlorians
packed into each one of the trillions of cells
in their body.
If you’re curious about your own midichlorian
count, the easiest way to figure that out
is with a simple blood test.
For most people though, knowing their midichlorian
count isn’t all that important.
You can lead just as healthy a life with a
count of 1,500 as you can with a count of 7,000.
Personally, I’m at about 3,700 for those
of you who might be wondering.
When you start to get to counts closer to
10,000, well, that’s when things start to
become… interesting.
You see, the higher your midichlorian count
is, the more likely you are to be able to
connect with the force - that energy field
created by all living things.
A field that surrounds us, and penetrates
us, and binds the whole frickin galaxy together.
And for those people with midichlorian counts
around 10,000, the chances of being able to
harness and use the force are so high, that
if their skills are discovered at a young
enough age, they have a good chance of being
trained to become a Jedi.
In fact, all of the samples we’re looking
at today come from the collection stored in
the archives at the Jedi Temple on Coruscant.
This sample here was taken from Jedi Master
Bolla Ropal when he was just 3 years old and
it shows that he had a midichlorian count
of just over 11,000, putting him somewhere
around Jedi Master Plo Koon, but far below
that of Anakin Skywalker who has a count of
well over 20,000.
Now, obviously, not all of us get to be Jedi,
and you shouldn’t feel like bantha fodder
if your midichlorian count is lower than average.
People with lower midichlorian counts have
been known to be force sensitive in the past,
even if it's not quite as common.
But looking at the bigger picture, we must
remember that without midichlorians life could
not exist.
And without them we would have no knowledge
of the force at all.
The midichlorians are continually speaking
to us, telling us the will of the force and,
with time, you can also learn to quiet your
mind and hear them speaking to you.
In those moments when I’m trying to sit
back and quiet my mind, I always find it helpful
to reflect on the words of the great Jedi
Master Qui-Gon Jinn,
“Your focus determines your reality.”
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us,
and may the force be with you.
Also thank you to all of our patrons on Patreon, all of these people
who let us, you know, do this on April 1st,
when maybe we all need a little bit of relaxation
and distraction.
If you’d like to see more from our Jedi
Master of Microscopes James Weiss, check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you would like to follow us deeper
into the galaxy that lies just beneath our sight
you can go to youtube.com/microcosmos.